what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it actually looks
like and no I'm not kidding Mephisto is
coming to the MCU we knew he was there
all along we knew it however he never
actually showed up but today we do have
news about Mephisto making his MCU debut
what exact project he's going to be in
and why he is actually making his MCU
debut so we're back to the good old one
division days of theorizing about
Mephisto however this time it's coming
in an actual report and we even have a
report about which actor is going to be
playing Mephisto in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so of course we'll get the
theories pumping at the end and
throughout the rest of the week and
month I'm sure but for now let's go over
this report talking about Mephisto and
the MCU and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU news so some of
you may heard that Borat himself the
actor who plays them Sasha Bara Cohen
was cast for Marvel's Iron Heart Disney
plus series apparently he was cast as a
different version of dormammu this came
from the account MCU status they
originally said on October 11th four
days ago we can confirm Sasha Bara Cohen
has joined the cast of ironheart and he
is playing a version of dormammu in the
comics Parker Robbins aka the hood uses
magic that is discovered to originate
from dormammu we know the hood is going
to be the main villain of the ironheart
series he is going to be using magic
against iron Hearts technology and
that's primarily what the story is going
to be about Magic versus Tech and also a
magically infused Tech as well which
should be pretty cool to see however
today they have actually updated their
report they said correction this one
time I can say I'm glad to update a
rumor Sasha bear Cohen may be playing a
dark lord but it isn't dormammu the
moment fans have been waiting for since
one division is here Sasha will finally
bring Mephisto to the MCU in ironheart
now for those asking about the validity
of this my time to shine hello the
account on Twitter who has been known to
post insanely accurate leaks online she
came out and said it's true and I love
it perfect casting she went on to say
the hood is the villain of the show he's
a Magic based character that makes a
deal with a demon to get his cloak and
Powers originally it was with Thor Mamu
in the comics but here it's gonna be
with Mephisto she also clarified that
Mephisto is going to be a long-term
character and that we are just getting a
taste of Mephisto here in the Iron Heart
series now here's another interesting
thing that my time to shine hello said
she said that fun fact they wanted
Giancarlo Esposito for that role first
but looks like he turned it down now
recently Giancarlo Esposito has come out
and publicly stated that yes he has met
with Marvel Studios but he wants to play
Professor Xavier he straight up came out
and said that now it clearly looks like
Marvel wanted him for Mephisto instead
of Professor Xavier so who knows where
he's sitting now with Marvel Studios but
if he got his way he might be playing a
Professor Xavier but going back to
Mephisto Sasha bear Cohen I think would
actually make a Great Mephisto of course
every time I see him I'll be quoting
Borat but still I think he'd make a
Great Mephisto I think the look that he
could have for this character would be
truly fantastic and I think he would be
a great actor to have in the MCU for a
long period of time this could really
bring us that darker Supernatural side
of the MCU we got Moon Knight we got
werewolf by night we're going into blade
now we'll have a project introducing
Mephisto and then I'm assuming Mephisto
is going to pop up in Agatha coven of
chaos that simply just makes sense after
the whole West View event and Agatha
Harkness losing to the Scarlet Witch and
the fact that the Scarlet Witch is out
there and alive is known now Mephisto
could show up to talk to Agatha after
all Agatha did have the dark hold and
that would probably interest Mephisto
but she lost it to Wanda then the
Scarlet Witch wreaked havoc upon the
universe this is something that might
interest Mephisto and since apparently
he is going to be around for a while in
the MCU this would make sense that he
would pop up in other shows especially
other shows that are focused around
magic specifically dark magic it just
makes sense so it looks like we weren't
too crazy to talk about Mephisto so much
in one division we even basically
thought that they confirm Mephisto is
indeed in the MCU in She-Hulk and it
looks like we were right but I'm only
imagining that it's going to get much
crazier from here and the theories are
also going to get a lot crazier as well
so let me know your thoughts about all
of this in the comments down below what
do you think of the casting choice and
where do you think Mephisto is going to
pop up besides of course the ironheart
series in the MCU let me know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
for live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf